right here in the lobby of Ramsay
Solutions Kyle and Elizabeth are with us
hey guys how are you hey Dave we're
doing well yeah better than we deserve
good to have you guys where are you from
Riverhead New York Long Island on Long
Island oh nice beautiful area very cool
well welcome to Nashville and you're
here to do your debt-free scream out
here cool and how much have you paid off
seventy two thousand five hundred
dollars all right and how long did that
take you took us three years three years
making what kind of money how we started
about twenty four thousand into the 8080
Wow he's a huge increase during the
three years when you do to increase your
income that much Elizabeth got a job
okay I was living overseas with Harding
University's international study abroad
program and after we got married
Elizabeth join me over there and she
couldn't use her speech pathology while
she was there until we moved back to the
States
gotcha okay so your speech pathologist
all right very cool
and what do you do Kyle we both work for
Timothy Hill Children's Ranch their
overhead New York okay we were
caretakers and we also work as
administrators and teachers they're very
neat so what happened three years ago
tell me your story of getting out of
that well three years ago is when we got
married three years this month so that
amount is our combined amount from when
we got married but it's all student debt
and when we got married I had been
working on mine individually and he had
as well he had heard about Dave Ramsey
and had friends that had taken your
classes but I wasn't really on a
specific plan just trying to not get out
as I could and when I married Kyle he
was had a plan and showed me you know
the debt snowball and explained
everything and so got me on board and
said this is how we're gonna do it and
so that's what we did
then we went about the business of doing
it okay so how much how long have you
been doing what you're currently doing
with the with that particular ranch what
Timothy children it's what we have been
there two years okay so two of the three
you were making the 80 or thereabout
okay all right but but the 24 was just
for the first portion in other words of
the experience
yeah and then because that makes the
math work in my hand isn't looking at
paying off seventy three thousand
dollars that's very impressive so you
guys are obviously very ministry minded
yes sir and and if you know chosen to
live out your careers in that
methodology using that way and and yet a
found a way that they furnish housing
where you are so you don't have a
housing cause that's one of the
blessings that we have working with the
ranch and one thing also that we've done
Dave is while we've been there and been
teaching we came in 2014 to the
financial coach master series uh-huh so
both of us are coaches up there in
Riverhead and with our residents and
others in the area Wow very cool well
thank you for doing that
so you're spreading this around and we
also we also use your curriculum the
foundations and personal finance with
our residents yeah with the kids
all right so how many kids are at this
ranch well right now we have about 50
and we range from about 13 years old to
25 very neat very neat well thank you
guys thank you very much you and
congratulations how's it feel
three years in to actually be here and
be debt-free it's very exciting feels
great yeah we're it's like a burden
that's lifted so feel like we can
actually do stuff now I came in with the
plan and you know and activated and we
wanted to finish and finish strong and
as we were getting married and wanting
to start a family we I knew that the
importance of doing that debt-free and
just the way they will give us the
opportunity to do more and to serve more
and to give more you know as you teach
and as you say and we're just blessed to
be able to do that and now that we're
expecting our first child in June
alright congratulations yeah so as you
guys were going through this I'm sure
the folks at the ranch were very
supportive obviously but did you have
people off in the distance throwing
grenades and going yeah you can't count
it wacky not really throwing grenades
but I mean we had people who you know
like good for you but not really that's
not really our soda man
congratulations you guys very cool so I
mean your counselors or coaches you've
been through our training you're
teaching the kids the same stuff there
at the ranch you've done it what are the
secrets to getting out of that well I
mean one thing for me I would say is
just being consistent you know we have
our monthly budget meetings and that's
something I wasn't doing before we
married and just being consistent and
setting our priorities correctly
each month is we're deciding where is
the money gonna go and we really got to
attack the debt first and once we do
that then we can do the other things and
so the consistency I would say very good
like that and and and Dave you mention
your books but that being content and
being happy with what you have and not
being in want and as we look through
Psalms and David talks but you know the
Lord is our Shepherd I shall not be in
want and not wanting and taking that
plan and saying this is what I want to
do in X number of years and following
through and doing that and so as it's
been a challenge for us to be debt-free
we've told that to our residents that we
live with it hey here's the debt we have
we don't want you to follow in that
footsteps and we want to lead and we
want to show you that you can't overcome
obstacles and now here we are there you
go yeah and and you you know you've been
another type of example to them one more
type of witness and they get to see
there's this sharp young couple starting
their family completely debt-free it's a
great model for these kids at the ranch
really yes congratulations thank you
very very well done I love it well I'm
very proud of you guys I'm proud that we
had a little part two in this and we
appreciate all the things you're doing
to help others with that information
very cool stuff Kyle and Elizabeth from
Long Island New York 73 thousand dollars
paid off in three years
making twenty four to eighty thousand
during that time new baby on the way
life is good count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three
way to go you two
very very well done I love it
congratulations man that is fabulous
you know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express gonna call my house and ask my
wife why she would stay with a man that
won't pay his bills